all right I am taking requests and
somebody requested a tour of Leviathan
so here we are in the parking lot and
I'll take you on a little tour
that's our limousine which when you get
to the foot passenger ferry appear
hopefully we'll pick you up in that big
truck to do a lot of construction going
on in the winters when Mark loads all
the work and I'm here early helping out
tractor painted car bunch of pallets
painted doors and this this is the gate
this is the entrance to Leviathan all
right this this has recently been this
is being turned into a garden for
raspberries so it's much a soil right
now
[Music]
forest that's like the storage kitchen
down there lots of trees we're doing
lots of gardening this is more soil
where we're gonna plant wild flowers to
our sink outdoor barbecue this is what
I'm super excited about so it's all soil
right now but I have spent the last the
last couple weeks creating all these I
mean I started last summer but these are
all for wildflowers this is our like
outdoor lounge area so in another month
it's all going to be a balloon with the
butterflies and hummingbirds and whatnot
today I was getting to help buck up and
clear some trees that were dying um and
a lot more light gets through now which
is awesome for the garden
that is Leviathan from the outside this
Lots a little touched I mean it's all
very rustic and primitive here but I
like things like this old wood stove
that's now a planter the door now
everything is a construction zone right
now but not changes when people start
arriving this is where all the food gets
cooked so proper proper old-school wood
stove because made by the Amish I mean
it's a new old-school wood stove our
very rustic kitchen where all the food
gets made and dishes gets washed and
these are the dining tables this dining
table right now is obviously a more like
a workbench for tools but that changes
dude do dishes and the studio kind of
hard to believe it exists we have a gong
because of course you need a gone
there's various beds around so people
who come to the retreats people often
claim an indoor bed everybody else camps
there's a couple of cabins you can rent
or you can for a fee Mark's got some big
deluxe tenth you can put a mattress in
and this is it this is licensed to do
and what you can't really see in the
video is um it's a sprung floor so the
whole floor is built on top of tires and
you don't doesn't you don't really
notice at first but because it's got
such a spring to it your feet your knees
don't get tired the way they would on a
more solid floor so it's like a ballet
dance floor and what I've seen is people
play forever here when I do a play
retreat just for hours and hours and
hours and I don't know if they know why
but I do it's because their feet don't
get tired so it's just the most awesome
floor I've ever done
a pulley event at um when people are
here we pull some more couches and
cushions around this is our wood stove
super cozy last year I built this
platform which is our other lounge area
and movie-watching area super nice
there's always some more a couple more
beds will be set up back there and big
wood pile um I didn't want to work here
I split all this wood and carried all
the wood from all over the property
bucked it up split it up because I had a
vision of player treats we're we're all
snug around a wood stove and lo and
behold that's exactly what it's been
like the last two years and it's so nice
so this is the inside studio that's
water comes for a good quality filter my
shoes back on uh see up here I've been
doing a lot of gardening this is what I
call the upper garden quite a large
garden um
I planted various vegetables radishes
and lettuce and beans cauliflower oh and
I also sprinkled wild flowers so I'll
let the vegetables and the wild flowers
Duke it out see who wins see what
happens outdoor seating area when it
gets hot in the summer people sit up
there often although our new lounge area
draws a lot of people now it has is
that's what you got it has is very
rustic here there's super artsy though
and nice artwork see after watch your
step because everything is very nikkor
it's your living kind of like half in
the forest when you're here so this is
the last garden I've been working on
doesn't look like much right now
what's your soil it's gonna be more
wildflowers
my idea is bees and hummingbirds lots of
bees and butterflies and hummingbirds
buzzing and fluttering all around the
studio so the last year's project you
asked marked if I can build the cabin
because I wanted to build a heaven and I
always liked this spot here so I built
this cabin by the pond
[Music]
pretty cool you cozy yeah it's pretty
messy
I'm slob it's got a nice here sorry the
lighting system by the LED strip and I
put the bottles on top of the LEDs at
all
lights up
[Music]
so this is all off grid the whole island
is off grid so there's solar panels all
over the place there's solar panels down
there and the solar panels up there and
mark somebody's donated a lot of solar
panels set for being the Commission's so
he took a big truck and went and got
Moll
it's a cabin that Mark built this is the
wood pile that I've been working on next
year's wood and this is a forest the
skeety island is mostly forest and
that's the last cabin there those are
free-range chickens doing chicken things
no change
that's basically their indoor chicken
coop space but the doors open so they
can come and go as they please
[Music]
that's right I mean it's a rugged here
as you can see it's always a work in
progress
um this is the vegetable garden I have
not been very involved with this
[Music]
it's currently a lot of kale that's over
running the whole garden but the coming
month tender loving care we put into
that garden big Long Pond as you can see
[Music]
that's a really nice area gets Sun all
afternoon so this whole area sort of
people hang out in sunbathe sure
everything like this trail so it's a big
property and there's always trees
falling down under trees Saturday and
have to be cut down so they don't fall
on somebody and kill them
part of what I get to do is to help take
down and move off the trees
most of Leviathan is built with the wood
from the property and whenever possible
wood that had to come down anyway but
it's pretty much all been built with
materials right here over there it's a
portable sawmill I was getting to use
last summer that cabin I built I I sawed
the lid myself I made all those boards
so this is like a dorm there's a few
beds up there don't expect too much it's
very primitive like I say and so but
there's a few mattresses up there this
is
lisanna that's you would they run the
song a lot in this summer for yay I
don't know if you'll be able to see
anything
probably not so in there is a sauna but
you can't see it because it's dark and
last but not least the Apthorp
it spawned water
[Music]
everything we had a weird amount of of
pollen this year I think the cedar trees
gave off huge amount of pollen for some
reason so everything has like a layer of
yellow dust on it including the ponds
and it doesn't always have that film on
Cup but I like the spot you can sit here
watch the water bugs and listen to the
birds
yeah so that's the vibe and a lot of
reasons I like it here the center of it
all is definitely that dance floor
because it's just epic I try not to use
that word too much but that dance floor
that studio is just the ultimate place
to play it boy I've done retreats this
year will be the seventh year I don't
know how many people will be able to
have here this year because of pandemic
but if nothing else a few friends will
be able to come we're hoping we can have
more people but time will tell so you're
welcome to send me an email to know
whether it's happening or not and I
don't know if it'll happen anymore I
love it
but I I never get enough people to make
really I don't make any money from it I
mean I make a little bit but not enough
for I keep having my whole life for
revolving around it unless I can find
some other job where I have the
flexibility to take time off for things
like this but I've been getting stressed
at what money in the last year's and I
need to make some big life decisions and
figure out how to take better care of
myself that way so Leviathan may or may
not continue depending on how I start
solving some of my life decision things
so what are you but hopefully something
happens this summer and we'll see what
the future brings but this has been a
pretty special place big part of my life
the last seven years
and if I do it this year and next year
those are probably your chances to come
and enjoy it with me we'll see I'm it
was a little miserable to get here I had
to go through days and airports and then
quarantine and the tiny air B&B in
Vancouver and it's all a lot of stress
but I have to admit now that I'm here it
was a pretty good decision to get myself
here it's just little lonely it's just
me and Mark and random guy who starts
who's been showing up in the background
of my videos hopefully he's gone now
okay I'll reporting in soon with